[Music]
welcome to the latest series from aj+
untold America San Francisco Chinatown
is the oldest Chinatown in America
there's not too many places left in the
world like this we're all about telling
the stories of the underrepresented and
misunderstood communities that make up
our country what does it mean to be both
Iranian and American I'm telling the
story of Syrians in America I'm in a way
telling my own story by speaking with
people on the ground when people think
of Chicago I think oh my god it's a
violent place with crazy people I mean
that's not the truth we don't look like
American people join us as we visit a
new community each month to learn more
about their place in US history what
they're facing today and how they're
preserving their culture for future
generations
follow us for more untold America
[Music]